You all know that.
I always say don't DFI politicians, these
are just people.
They are flawed people.
Sometimes they want to do things we agree
with.
Sometimes they don't.
But the idea of holding politicians up and
I don't care if it's the Magga crowd or Bernie
or bust or the Tulsi people or whoever.
I don't recommend defying any politician,
but that doesn't mean that there can be real
material, important differences between one
politician and another.
And the civil unrest and protests that we've
been seeing this week are providing a really
good case study to look at some of the differences.
Donald Trump sat at the White House tweeting,
threatening to deploy the military to states.
And on one day this week, used police to gas
protesters and used horses to disperse protesters
so that he could walk over to St. John's and
get a picture.
Awkwardly holding a Bible.
That's what Trump did.
Meanwhile, Joe Biden and Nancy Pelosi and
Elizabeth Warren have actually gone and met
with protesters and talked to protesters and
even marched with protesters in some cases.
This doesn't make them perfect people.
It doesn't make Democrats uber progressive.
It doesn't make them gods.
It doesn't do anything other than show us.
There is a really stark contrast right now
in terms of how completely out of his element,
an impotent Donald Trump is, how unable to
lead.
The president is that he can't even do the
simple things that many elected officials
are doing.
Yesterday, Nancy Pelosi, as we are showing
you on video, went out to the protests in
Washington, D.C., spoke to protesters, walked
around, was part of what was going on.
Doesn't mean anything in particular about
Nancy Pelosi's policy positions.
But it does tell us that she's at least out
there seeing what's going on and talking to
people.
Does this make Nancy Pelosi some progressive
change maker?
Now, she's a moderately left establishment
Democrat, but Trump is hiding out and tweeting.
OK.
It's the contrast that matters.
Yesterday, I told you about Democratic Massachusetts
Senator Elizabeth Warren.
She went out to participate in a march on
the streets in Washington, D.C., brought her
husband along, brought her dog along.
We're showing our video audience some video
of that right now.
And again, making it very clear she was asked,
why is Trump sending out the military?
She said, well, because he's wrong.
Joining protesters, talking to people, being
out there, being part of our community rather
than someone sitting at the White House in
the Oval Office or even, you know, in a bunker,
as Donald Trump did did briefly on Friday,
sending out tweets and mobilizing forces and
putting up fence after fence after fence,
as I don't know if you saw, but significant
new fencing being erected around the White
House area.
Likewise, Democratic presidential candidate
Joe Biden going out even earlier than Nancy
Pelosi, even earlier than Elizabeth Warren
to talk to protesters to understand what's
going on.
Making a speech about the systemic elements
that are at play and what these protests are
meant to illuminate.
And a deal with Biden, Pelosi and Warren do
not deserve our support just because they
met with protesters.
We still need to be thinking critically about
every single one of these individuals and
who we vote for.
But the point is there is an absolute total
minimum as public officials that should be
done just to show you're even remotely engaged
with what's going on out there.
It is about contrast with Donald Trump.
Trump stayed at the White House and tweeted
insults.
He went to his bunker.
He walked over to a church and held up a Bible
that Ivana Trump carried over for him in a
fifteen hundred dollar purse for a photo op
after protesters were dispersed with smoke
and huge horses.
There's just no comparison in terms of how
unfit to lead the president is.
This is just the latest, latest example.
Now, let's deal with some of the critiques.
Many of you might no doubt say K. Biden, Warren
and Pelosi.
They went out there.
But what have they actually done?
And that's a fair question.
Biden's not even in an elected position right
now.
So what can he do other than say, here's what
I would do as president?
But they are actually there.
They're in the midst of what's happening compared
to our easily trigger able president who can't
even be bothered to do any work at this point,
never mind engage with the problems that the
country is dealing with in a way that doesn't
seem patronizing or that will actually make
the problem worse.
I keep going back to one of the thoughts I
keep going back to as the protests started
because of anger about treatment of black
men by police.
Police using too much.
Horse police being too brutal.
And what Donald Trump does is say, hey, you
know what, the governors aren't deploying
enough law enforcement force.
They're not doing enough shows of strength.
I'm going to override them and send in the
military as if more law enforcement force
is the solution to protests, protesting about
too much law enforcement force being used.
It's inconceivable.
There is it's hard to think of someone more
poorly suited to lead at this point in time.
Corona virus already proved it.
The protests are only the latest example.
And we've got five months.
We've got five months.
And we are ultimately going to decide what
happens next.